you may by now be familiar with the tape
the notion of evaluating a function at a
particular value so for example if this
table is our function definition if
someone were to say well what is f of
negative 9 you'd say okay if we input
negative 9 into our function if x is
negative 9 this table tells us that f of
x is going to be equal to 5.
and you might already have experience
with doing composite functions where you
say
f of let's say actually f of f of
negative nine
plus one
so this is interesting it seems very
daunting would you say well we know what
f of negative nine is this is going to
be five so it's going to be f of five
plus one so this is going to be equal to
f of
and if we look at our table f of 6 is
equal to
negative 7.
so all of that is a review so far but
what i want to now do is start
evaluating the inverse of functions and
this function f is invertible because
it's a one-to-one mapping between the
x's and the f of x's no two x's map to
the same f of x and so this is an
invertible function so with that in mind
let's see if we can evaluate something
like
f inverse
of eight what is that going to be i
encourage you to pause the video and try
to think about it
all right so f of x just as a reminder
of what functions do f of x
is going to map from this domain
from a value in its domain to a
corresponding value in the range
in the range so this is what f does
so this is domain
domain
and this right over here is going to be
the range now f inverse if you pass it
the
the value in the range it'll map it back
to the corresponding value in
the corresponding value in the domain
but how do we think about it like this
well f inverse of eight this is whatever
maps to eight so if this was eight we
have to say well what mapped to 8
well we see here f of 9 is 8.
f of 9 is 8. so f inverse of 8 is going
to be
is going to be equal to and actually we
do this in that same color is going to
be equal to nine
and if it makes it easier we could
actually construct a table here and this
is actually what i probably would do
just to make sure i'm not doing
something strange where i could say x
and f inverse of x
and what i essentially do is i'd swap
these two columns
so
f of x goes from negative nine to five f
inverse of x is going to go from five
to negative nine all i did is i swapped
these two now we're mapping from this to
that
so f inverse of x is going to map from 7
to negative 7. notice instead of going
from this mapping from this thing to
that thing we're not going to map from
that thing to that thing so f inverse is
going to map from 13 to 5.
13 to 5 is going to map from negative 7
to 6
negative 7 to 6. it's going to map from
8 to 9.
8 to 9 and it's going to map from 12 to
from 12 to 11. so let's see did i do
that right yeah it looks like i got all
of yep so all i did is really i just
swapped these columns it's mapping the f
inverse maps from this column to that
column so i just swapped them out so now
it becomes a little bit clear that way
you see it right over here f inverse of
if if you input 8 into f inverse you get
9.
so now we can use that to start doing
fancier things we can evaluate something
like
f inverse
f inverse of actually let's let's
evaluate this let's evaluate f of
f of
f
inverse
of
let's see f of f inverse of seven
what is this going to be well let's
first evaluate f inverse of seven f
inverse of seven maps from seven to
negative seven maps from seven to
negative seven so this is going to be f
of this stuff in here
in yellow this stuff in here f inverse
of 7 we see is negative 7. so it's going
to be f of negative 7 and then to
evaluate the function well f of negative
7 that's just going to be 7 again
and that makes complete sense we
essentially went we mapped from 7 f
inverse of 7 went from 7 to negative 7
and then evaluating the function of that
went back to
went back to 7.
so let's do let's do one more of these
just to really feel comfortable with
mapping back and forth between these two
sets between applying the function and
the inverse of the function
so let's evaluate what
do in purple
f
i mean now that wasn't purple so it's
going let's try to evaluate f uh f
inverse
of f inverse
of
of f inverse of 13. what is that going
to be i encourage you to pause the video
and try to figure it out
well what's f inverse of 13
well that's looking at this table right
here f inverse goes from 13
to 5. and you see it over here f went
from 5 to 13 so f inverse is going to go
from 13 to 5.
so this right over here f inverse of 13
is just going to be 5. so this whole
thing is the same thing as f inverse of
5.
and f inverse of 5 well f inverse goes
from 5 to negative 9.
so this is going to be equal to negative
9. once again f inverse goes from 5 f
goes from negative 9 to 5 so f inverse
is going to go from 5 to negative 9. so
at first when you start doing these kind
of inverse and function and inverse of a
function it looks a little confusing hey
i'm going back and forth we just have to
remember a function maps from one set of
numbers to another set of numbers and
the inverse of that function goes the
other way so if we if the function goes
from nine to eight the inverse is going
to go from eight to nine so one way to
think about is you just kind of switch
these columns hopefully that that
clarifies more things that it confuses